with every passing year
a dependence on digital technology
increases 10-4
we book transport via mobiles and shop
clothes on our laptops
among all these nitty-gritty day-to-day
activities information such as payment
authentication
personal data and private credentials
are transported over the internet
with various website partners with this
reliance on the internet
as gradual its impact has been every bit
as definite
this statistic represents the daily time
spent online
by internet users worldwide starting
from 2011
all the way up to 2021 sorted by device
according to zenith optimedia in 2018
the average daily minutes of desktop
internet consumption per capita
amounted to 39 minutes and it is slowly
projected to decline until 2020.
however the daily mobile internet
consumption is set to
increase to 155 minutes in 2021.
if our current lifestyle is any
indication of the future
these statistics are just a window into
what is going to be a future full
of artificial intelligence and its
derivatives
as observed by researchers around the
world this level of dependability has
made us vulnerable to the worst of the
internet
according to the forbes magazine in 2019
the cumulative damage and cost of cyber
effect are far more significant
than those inflicted by natural
disasters in a year
every 11 seconds a business falls victim
to a ransomware attack
the average cost of a data breach in
2020 is 3.86 million dollars
the huge increase in cyber crimes is a
major contributor
to the 12 annual growth rate of
cybersecurity spending
the united states has the world's
highest average data breach crossed
at 6.84 million dollars as per 2020
records
opportunities breed innovation and this
has been observed in the cyber security
domain
as well to safeguard against such
threats the ssl protocol was developed
hey everyone this is biaber from simply
learn and welcome to this video on the
ssl handshake
let's look at the topics we have to
cover today
we first take a look at the origin and
the basics of the ssl protocol in the
networking segment
we understand the core values of the
secure ssl layer
and the protection it provides against
various malicious attacks and domains
next we learn about the four distinct
sub-protocols to be found under the ssl
flag
all the way up to a step-by-step
explanation on how the ssl handshake
is initiated until its completion
finally we learn about the future of ssl
and the implications it may have on the
immediate generation of internet
security
we also have a quiz in between the
topics so stay focused and let's see if
you can answer the question
let us learn about the ssl protocol
first
ssl or secure sockets layer is an
encryption based internet security
protocol
it was first developed by netscape in
1995
for the purpose of ensuring privacy
authentication
and data integrity in internet
communication
ssl is the predecessor to the modern tls
encryption news today
it acts as a cryptographic layer
protocol that provides privacy and
security to communication
between a client and a web server
a website that implements ssl
authentication has
https in its url instead of http
in order to provide a high degree of
privacy ssl
encrypts data that is transmitted across
the web this means that anyone who tries
to intercept this data
will only see a garbled mix of
characters that is nearly impossible to
decrypt
ssl initiates an authentication process
called a handshake
between two communicating devices to
ensure that both of them
are really who they claim to be ssl also
digitally signs
data in order to provide data integrity
the internet we use today follows an osi
model
or even systems interconnections model
it is a priority system that
characterizes
and standardizes the communication on
the internet
among its multiple layers the ssl layer
functions between the application layer
and the transport layer the application
layer provides services for an
application
to ensure that effective communication
with another applic program
is possible the transport layer is
responsible for error-free
end-to-end delivery of data from the
source host to the destination host
since the ssl protocol functions in
between these two layers
the data is encrypted and is
authenticated after being passed through
the application
and before it is transmitted over the
network to further understand this
priority table
let us look at the table of how it works
hypertext transfer protocol http is an
application layer protocol that is used
for transmitting information between
computers on the world wide web
http is based on a request response
standard between a client and server
once the data is ready to be shared we
can pass it on to the ssl layers
as you can notice the protocol being
used right now is http
which signifies that the data is
unencrypted and hence vulnerable to
malicious attacks
the data is then passed on to the ssl
where we have the record protocol for
the confidentiality protection
and the handshake protocol for the
authentication of client and server
the sub-protocols of the ssl will be
later discussed in detail
after the data is encrypted and ready to
be transmitted
it is moved on to the transport layer
where we use the tcp packets to send
their data
along to the internet layer and from
that point forward
the data can move to its destination
using the internet protocol
or ip addressing tables
with so many sub-protocols and
sub-variants of the ssl protocol
the work is divided into multiple layers
and aspects
let's have a look at some of the ways
the ssl layer make the internet
safe and secure
for server authentication the client
uses the server's public key to encrypt
the data
which is used to complete the secret key
the server can generate the secret key
only if it can decrypt the information
with the correct private key
for client authentication the server
uses the public key in the client
certificate
if any of the authentication steps fail
the handshake fails
and the session terminates this exchange
of digital certificates during the ssl
handshake
is a part of the authentication process
ssl provides data integrity by
calculating a message digest or a hash
use of ssl does ensure integrity
provided that the cipher spec
in your channel definition uses a hash
algorithm
in the ssl record protocol the hash
value is generated for the data to be
transmitted
hence providing a necessary way to
verify data corruption
ssl uses a combination of symmetric and
asymmetric encryption to ensure message
privacy
during the ssl handshake the ssl client
and server
agree to an encryption algorithm and a
shared secret key is used for that
particular session
all the messages transmitted between the
client and server
are then encrypted using the same
algorithm and key
that ensure that the message will remain
private even if it is intercepted
regarding the multiple layers in the ssl
protocol we have many sub protocols that
ensure the three protection aspects of
security
let us learn more about these
the ssl record protocol provides two
services to the ssl connection
confidentiality and message integrity
in ssl record protocol the data is
divided into fragments
the fragment comprises of the encrypted
sha code
and the md5 code after the encryption of
the data is done
the last ssl header is also appended to
the data
the handshake protocol is used to
establish sessions
this protocol allows the client and
server to authenticate each other by
sending a series of messages
handshake protocol uses four phase
system to complete its cycle
in phase one both the client and server
send hello packets to each other
in phase two they exchange the
certificates with the correct private
and public keys
in phase three they reply to each other
with the encryption
algorithms and the secret keys while in
phase 4
the handshake is completed
for the chain cipher spec protocol we
use a part of the ssl record protocol
unless handshake is completed the ssl
record output will be in a pending state
after handshake the pending state is
converted into a current state
the chain cipher protocol consists of a
single message
which is a one byte inlet and can hold
only one value
the ssl alert protocol is used to convey
ssl related alerts to the peer entity
each message in this protocol contains
only two bytes
let's take a small quiz to check if the
older topics are clearly understood
once the data is encrypted in the ssl
layer
where is the data being passed on to is
it a
the application layer b transport layer
see the internet layer or the
presentation layer
take a few seconds to recall our last
topic and be sure to leave your answer
in the comments section of this video
let's move on with our topic now that we
understand the entire protocol and it's
working
let's see how the ssl handshake works in
a step-by-step format
we have divided the handshake into four
distinct phases
in phase one the client and server get
acquainted with the hello signal
message from each site the client sends
the ssl version
cipher suit and the session id the
server returns an encryption algorithm
which is chosen from the cipher suit and
a compression algorithm which is sent
from the client hello
signal each this helps in setting up a
common encryption algorithm
and a common hash value to be used
throughout the handshake process
in phase 2 the server sends it
authentication certificate
and requests for client authentication
the server also sends its public
encryption key
and the phrase with the server hello
done message
once the server sends its public key the
client can use it to
encrypt its own private key which will
be later used to encrypt the data being
exchanged between the client
and a server in phase 3
the client sends its authentication
certificate after verifying the server
with the respective certificate
authorities
the client now send a private key which
is encrypted using the server's
previously sent
public key
in phase 4 the client sends the status
of the cipher functions
along with a finished message to end the
handshake from its side
the server also sends the status of the
cipher algorithm
and ends with a finished signal the data
is now encrypted with a symmetric key
client
sent in phase 3. with the end of phase 4
authentication is complete and the ssl
handshake has maintained the
authenticity of the entire session
between the client and server
to reiterate the entire process
let's go through each step one more time
the client sends a hello request to the
server
the server responds with its own hello
message and sends the server
authentication certificate for
verification
at this point the server's hello signal
is complete
the client exchanges a secret key with
the server to encrypt the data
and the cipher spec parameters are
changed accordingly
the client has now finished its own
handshake activities
the server uses the secret key provided
by the client to encrypt the data
and alters its own cipher spec
parameters as a final step
before it sends a finished signal
at this point the ssl handshake is
complete with an encryption algorithm
and a secure data channel to transmit
information
with ssl protocol being developed in the
early 90s
it was bound to be a little underpowered
when pitted against the current day
computers and hackers
let's see its future implications and
replacements
ssl encryption has been depreciated now
with its version 2 and version 3
being docked by the internet engineering
task force in 2011 and 2015 respectively
there had been far too many security
vulnerabilities to carry on official
activities during the ssl
prayer to further enhance the security
the transport layer security or tls has
been developed as a successor to the ssl
protocol
tls is a proposed ietf standard first
developed in 1999
and the current version is tls 1.3 which
was defined in august 2018.
even though a major part of the internet
is still using tls 1.2 as a safety net
the transition to the latest version
should be completed before any security
deficiencies are exploited
hope you learned something interesting
today if you have any questions
regarding the topic we learned today
feel free to leave your comments and we
will get back to you as soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this and thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here